oh Lord
first up did you know that one in five
people suffer from misophonia it's a
condition where certain noises like
chewing tapping and breathing can cause
you to feel anxious and sometimes even
angry Sandra I think you suffer for this
I think I definitely I didn't know it
till we just did the segment I diagnosed
you I don't like the sound of people
clipping their nails
um if you ever heard somebody do that on
a train or something
plain oh of course
um I don't like the loud scent of the
like the hood the vent over your stove
just drives me bonkers and then if
you're cleaning the dishes I love my
husband but he pulls he turns the sink
on like full like I just you do you need
to run it when your husband does the
dishes you cannot complain I just
thought of that as I said it yeah no it
might not be a medical professional but
I'm going to urge you to see maybe
chewing if you're in a quiet room and
you have to hear somebody like you know
Chomp on their potato chips like it's I
don't you know I don't enjoy it I I
don't think it's just the chewing per se
it's like when people chew with their
mouths opening
I want us I want to slap but I want to
say did your mother know
yeah that's it Greg I don't know if this
is actually a disorder because nobody is
saying something that somebody likes
right so it's all basically the same you
already know what I don't like Drop tees
right I don't want to make a mountain I
don't want to make a mountain out of a
mohill but it's important to say your
t's
Like Richard Tyler
so outside of Jesse the three of y'all
should go seek medical attention
up next
to spoil their dog's rotten one guy
spend 10 thousands of dollars on a two
on a two-story compound of a
contemporary house for his Pooch with a
security camera smart lights and a
sliding door now judgingina rumor has it
that uh you like bought a house for your
pigs yes yes so so I'll make it real
fast so I'm reading Charlotte's Web to
my kids and they're like Mommy can we
have a Wilbur I said you're going to get
two wilbers so there's the Pig house
there's the pig near the barbecue Wilbur
and Homer they had their own house that
was heated because they were Vietnamese
Potbelly so I figured they're used to
the hot weather then I had a then I had
a concrete patio because I didn't want
them to sink in the mud do you know why
pigs roll in the mud
because they need to cool off so I
bought them a swimming pool and then I
put lights so the raccoons don't go in
there and beat them up now Greg you also
bought a house for your dog Gus
allegedly I hear that's you heard wrong
oh listen I'm just the producers
the dog doesn't know the difference
between being the homeless or living
with Lady Gaga and it sucks so your dog
was with Lady Gaga now what I'm saying
is I'm a rich and famous person and my
dog doesn't care and that really bums me
out if you steal Lady Gaga's dog is that
what you just said oh my God I'm the
real kidnapper so you're dog Shooters
I don't even know what's happening with
your dog and Lady Gaga Sandra
I don't spoil my dog at all everybody
spoils or not buying a house a little
bit much but I do have a house in the
woods that is essentially so my dog can
run so I cannot be a Critic of this
no I don't spoil my dog
why would you say that you let him run
in the creek that's what he likes judge
look at that haircut that's a nice
little job and then you clean them up no
I don't clean them the twins do I'll get
my hands dirty with that kind of stuff I
gotta keep my fingernails is that what
you call your hands the twins
I let the twins take care of that I have
a cat she's not spoiled and hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else